THERE'S ADAM FOX ON WITH RYAN
LINDGREN T
HERE'S KREIDER
JUST STEPPED IN AND INTERCEPTED,
GAMES.
TAGE THOMPSON WITH IT.
GAVE IT UP.
VATRANO WITH A TAKEAWAY.
VATRANO TO THE NETET
PUCK RIGHT THERE, TRIES TO MAKE
A PLAY, GIVES IT UP, F IS
GAMES.
GOOD HIT ON THE FORE-CHECK B SC.
ASPLUND.
SEES HIM.
SAMUELSSON.
HENRI JOKIHARJU CENTERS RIGHT
THROUGH THE CREASE.
BUTCHER SHOOTS AND SCORES.
WHATAT CORNER INTO THE FRONT
OF THE NET THAT ELUDES EVERYONE.
WATCH, HERE COMES THE PASS. CHA.
TROUBA WITH A GREATSTICK.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN 2-0 F F
ATTEMPT. NOT MUCH OF A SHOT
THERE.
YOUR GOALIE'S GOT TO STOP THAT,
AND HE'S GOTOT OR TO MAKE A
DEFENSIVE PLAY, THEN YPASS, SEN
LAFRENIERE ON A BREAKAWAY, AND
ANDERSON COMES UP
IT'S NOTSIDE.
SO BRODZINSKI,
THAT SHOT THE LEAGUE
TO CAROLINA.
BUFFALO'O'
RANGERS.
>> Joe: EXCELLENT START.
THEY'RE GETTING PUCK I SIDE OF
YOUR SCREEN.
WATCH HIM GO GET THE PUCK. BY p
HINOS
HINOSTROZA.
LINDGREN COMES OVER.
THEY SCORE!
JEFF SKINNER!
WHO REGULATION
TIMEME
BUFFALO, T.
POKED AWAY.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET IT TO
ZIBANEJAD.
LONG SHIFT FOR ZIBANEJAD. LAFRE.
NOW -- HE